my talk at the table guys is about a new
direction for the blockbuster game
franchise halo which has grossed more
than six billion dollars in total sales
since its debut in 2001. now the classic
video game is coming to your tv screen
excited actor pablo schreiber is known
for playing characters like mad sweeney
and american gods and for his emmy
nominated role as prison guard george
pornstash mendez
and orange is the new black i get to say
porn stash on tv he's starring in the
new paramount plus series halo as master
chief 117 a genetically engineered
soldier also known as a spartan it is
set in the 26th century when humanity
faces possible extinction by aliens
known as the covenant in this clip
master chief and his team are near the
landing site of the alien ship
master
now investigating the interior of a
nearby cave
[Music]
assessment report
covenant excavation
cave network does not appear to be a
natural formation
preserving debris consistent with plasma
cutters
covenant forces appear to be excavating
for some kind of object
i'm clear as to its nature
[Music]
and pablo schreiber joins us now good
morning good to see you nice to see you
guys how are you doing really good so so
let me ask you for those who are not
familiar well vlad is very food
i i bought you know microsoft their plan
was we're going to make halo available
only on the xbox yeah as a playstation
player for my whole life and i bought an
xbox just to play halos i've been
playing it since 2001. um but let's for
people who are not familiar well we need
both we need both chief yes yes who is
master chief and what does he stand for
uh yeah he's a symbol you know he's a
symbol for all of us for everyone who's
ever played halo he's a symbol uh for
bravery for courage for extraordinary
actions under very difficult
circumstances
and he's a stand-in for the player you
know you play the game and you play as
master chief
obviously now we're bringing him to a
television series a long form television
series we want to make multiple seasons
of this show and so for that purpose you
know we have to we have to get
underneath the armor we have to get to
know the man so a lot of the themes of
this show are you know breaking the
master chief down
and exploring the tension and and the
conversation between master chief the
soldier and john the man but what's
exciting pablo is that we get to see
your face because a lot of times listen
i watched the first two episodes we
didn't even see your face until 50
minutes in i'm not complaining but i was
really glad i was really glad when the
helmet came the gamers never saw it you
never see it in the game you never see
it ever saw it never see it in the game
and uh and so you know that's a big
moment in the in the halo franchise and
the history of halo is to to take the
helmet off but yeah it did feel like in
order to tell a very human story you
know
about a soldier who's exploring his own
identity um about the effects of war on
the society and the effects of war on
the individual in order to tell a story
like that over a long form you really
had to get underneath the helmet it's a
great it's a great humanizing moment
when you take the helmet off and it also
underscores how this is a great story
it's not just visually exciting it's not
just based on a video game people love
it's a truly great story oh man let me
tell you i i didn't know too much about
the halo franchise coming into it did
you play the game i played it you know
in in high school at friends houses i
didn't grow up with tv or video games no
tv in your house no tv are you okay
pablo i'm all right i'm all right don't
worry about me
uh yeah i grew up in rural british
columbia and uh and so i didn't have
access to the technology but through
high school i started to play but i
never played it as a story game i always
played it as a versus shooter so for me
the really uh the process of this has
been learning about how much mythology
and how much story has been spooled out
over the course of 20 years of this
franchise over multiple mediums yeah we
were talking about that tony and i uh
earlier and i said you know video games
are cinematic now yeah the characters
are as deep as any character you'll see
in film or television so what kind of
responsibility do you feel to the fans
who are going to expect certain things
from master chief huge responsibility
huge responsibility i mean the character
is iconic the character as i was saying
is a symbol for us you know so and for
so many people there's a co-ownership
they feel over the master chief because
you play as him right um so i'm aware of
that and and really uh have taken that
on and really want to do uh the fans
proud obviously um in the best way that
i can but even more than that you know i
want to bring in a new audience who has
never uh
interacted with the franchise before and
show all everyone who doesn't know
anything about halo why we love this
universe so much you were certainly
going to do that and it's interesting
your last name is well known because you
and leave are related growing up did you
both want to be actors is it something
you talked about as kids no we didn't
grow up together he he uh grew up on the
east coast i grew up on the west coast
we have the same father but our father
was an acting teacher so there's a
comment there's a common bond there um
but no you know so it's not like you
guys said let's be actors nope nope we
ended up there was no grand plan we just
we just landed here so uh i wanna i i'm
asked through the dumb question so i
have one about haley oh please i love
you i love dumb questions you got the
picture of the gear that you're wearing
uh how heavy is that gear and what was
it like getting into it every day and
trying to act yes it's not a dumb
question i know it's not a dumb question
that's awesome that's a very good
question yeah like you know um it was
about 55 pounds uh and it's not the
weight it's really like the fact that it
makes you quite immobile and these suits
are they're supposed to be future tech
you know they're supposed to turn these
guys into absolute super soldiers who
are incredibly capable of you know the
most amazing feats uh but really they
just stack about 55 pounds of plastic
onto you and send you out to shoot you
know so it's it's uh it's a challenge
certainly to to figure out how to
manipulate it in the best way to make it
come alive and make it look authentic
and feel real um but it's one that that
we were up for and and you know
obviously the honor of getting to wear
it and to be on set there every day yeah
it's just amazing and huge and and and i
loved being in it here's a dumb question
you make that costume look really good
and when you take off the helmet it goes
to another level because i'm thinking
right now he's very we don't see much
emotion from john but i'm thinking we're
going to see humanity as it goes along
we get through flashbacks yeah well
that's the process of of the first
season right yeah
interaction with an artifact that brings
back some memories from his childhood
and the process of the first season is
really john discovering his humanity for
the first time yeah um so this
introductory season is really getting uh
the audience comfortable with the
character so that we can um expand and
go even deeper and richer into into
places that uh will feel people are
gonna lie i'm here for it i'm here for
it uh pablo schreiber thank you very
much halo premieres march 24th on our
streaming service paramount plus